aloha my name is caitlin perrault and
i'm an assistant professor at chaminade
university of honolulu here in hawaii
today i'm going to be talking about uh
decomposition odor research how it's
been evolving in the last little while
and the impact that covet 19 has had
on research efforts in this area
so i wanted to start by sharing my
experience in a volunteer-led search
that i participated in last year for an
elderly missing person
it will come as probably no surprise to
you that as a forensic scientist we know
that
um we recognize we're often dealing with
the most challenging and sometimes
traumatic events in people's lives
in may of 2020 we spent over a month
looking for a missing person in one of
the most
expansive hiking trail systems here on
the island of oahu in hawaii
the system is about 1100 acres in total
and has over 15 miles of intertwined
trail systems with many additional minor
trails interwoven in between those
i got involved in the search because the
search lead reached out to me with
several questions about
odors that they were experiencing within
the trail system
scent detection canines were being
brought in daily with no definitive
results
enough time had elapsed that the hope of
finding a happy and healthy victim were
becoming quickly diminished
and for the family they were living
through some of the most the the worst
moments of their lives
daily while we traversed through
countless tracks in the vicinity
and this satellite map shows the extent
of searching and some of the key points
of interest where evidence and odors
were identified
it's in moments like this that i'm
reminded that my field of forensic
chemistry is actually rather unique and
still very much so under development
the questions that i was being asked
about the state of the body versus
potential odors that could be produced
could sometimes be answered based on our
research but not always
more often than not i was giving answers
like well it depends
and with deep gulches steep terrain
thick brush dangerous cliffs
and lots of decomposing wild pig
carcasses this search became strenuous
and frustrating for many community
members
eventually the victim was found resting
in a plot of land that would not have
been discovered without the key input
of volunteer searchers expert search
teams and other community members with
unique knowledge such as myself
this took place at a time when the kovid
19 pandemic was impacting the entire
world
may of 2020 for myself seeing a
community pulled together against the
additional challenges that this pandemic
brought
beyond the typical challenges of a
missing person scenario
made me hopeful it certainly made me
look inward to our discipline
how we're conducting research the impact
that the pandemic will have on those
research efforts
and where we should be moving forward in
the future so today
that's what i want to talk about where
this field of research has been
developing and where it's going to be
moving
and how some of these impacts from the
pandemic will affect things
so decomposition odor profiling is our
topic and
the first question might just be what is
this field
well in this field we look at volatile
organic compounds or vocs
these are basically just chemicals that
prefer to be a gas rather than a liquid
or a solid
and they are being produced throughout
the entire process of decomposition so
it changes over time from the point that
the
person dies to the point when they're
discovered and so the body is changing
and this odor is changing with that
and we can think of odor actually as a
forensic trace it's probably not the
first thing that comes to mind when we
think of forensic traces
but it can be exploited and used as
evidence
in particular cases so some of the
applications of this trace
would be to help understand and improve
cadaver detection dog training
where dogs are used to search for and
locate missing persons
victims of homicides and mass disasters
it can also be used to better understand
how insects are attracted to a body
throughout the course of decomposition
since this pattern can be used to help
understand times and steps
it can also be used to demonstrate the
presence of a body and there's actually
been a couple cases in the u.s and in
europe where
decomposition odor was collected as
evidence in a case
and used to show that a body was present
even after it had been moved to a
different location
there's also a lot of interest in using
some of these target molecules that we
detect in decomposition odor profiling
to develop handheld detection devices
that could be used in victim recovery
and finally it does help us to better
understand what's actually happening as
these remains are decomposing
so how the soft tissues are decomposing
eventually to the point where
remains are skeletal
and while while that's all very helpful
profiling this odor is actually very
challenging from an analytical chemistry
point of view
so i wanted to go through some of the
challenges here first
decomposition odor is a complex mixture
of hundreds if not thousands of
compounds
all mixed together these compounds also
exist in a variety of different compound
classes
and from an analytical perspective it's
difficult to
develop a method that's able to detect
all of those compound classes at the
same time
there's also a broad dynamic range
meaning that some compounds are very
high in abundance and some compounds are
very very trace in amounts
and having an analytical method that can
detect both of those concentration
ranges can be really tough
we also need to perform longitudinal
analysis meaning that we have to
understand
the odor as it evolves over time so
often times we're dealing with many many
samples because we're collecting from
the first point after death all the way
to the end of the study
also this odor is impacted by many
variables some of which we'll discuss
today
and finally we do non-targeted analysis
at this point because that's where this
field of research currently is
we care about every single compound
that's being produced by the body
and trying to understand how it changes
over time and with different variables
impacting it so since we want to know
every compound that's there that also
makes our job as analytical chemists
quite challenging because we need to
develop a method that can target
everything
so current studies have been performed
in a variety of different ways and this
area of research has really been being
developed since about 2004
the earlier studies looked at a single
point in time
mostly from bodies that were both
indoors and outdoors but
this this looked at a specific time
point
more recent studies have focused more on
looking at this decomposition process
and how it impacts odor over time
largely from bodies outdoors because
from a logistical standpoint if you're
going to be decomposing remains
having them outdoors has a lot of
benefits but in a variety of different
scenarios such as
bodies which are buried bodies which are
deposited
on the surface say on soil or on grass
remains that have been submerged and
those that have more recently in some
studies been placed under collapse
structures to simulate
mass disaster scenarios
studies have also looked at
decomposition of both human
and animal remains the animal remains
studies typically focus on susgrofo
domesticus which is the
a pig carcass and some of these studies
have been performed at tafenomic
research facilities sometimes you hear
those referred to as
body farms but these are outdoor
facilities where both
human and animal remains can be placed
to observe
and collect samples
so in collecting decomposition odor the
most common way of doing so
is by placing a large stainless steel
hood which you can see in the photo here
and you place that over top of the
remains so this hood is sitting over top
of a pig carcass
and what we do is we use a low flow
sampling pump which is essentially just
a low
uh flow vacuum and we use that to
withdraw air
through a sorbent tube this is a
stainless steel tube that's
on the inside it has a sorbent and that
basically just acts like a trap so as we
pull air through that sorbent tube
through teflon tubing and then through
the tube um our volatiles are going to
be trapped on this tube and then we can
take that back to the laboratory for
analysis
in the laboratory there are two types of
analytical instrumentation that are used
to analyze decomposition odor
the first is gas chromatography most
often with mass spectrometry
and the second is comprehensive
two-dimensional gas chromatography or
gcgc
one-dimensional gc is comprised of an
inlet
where we introduce our sample the inlet
is hot so it makes our sample into a
vapor
that vapor then gets swept onto a column
and that column is going to separate our
chemicals from one another
ideally what then happens is our
compounds will arrive at the end of the
column where a mass spectrometer will be
able to identify each of them
and tell us how much of each compound is
there and that is how we build the odor
profile
more recently studies have started to
use comprehensive two-dimensional gas
chromatography or gcgc
in this technique we have all of the
same components as one-dimensional gc
however we have two modulator and a
secondary column
what happens in this technique is as our
compounds come off
of the first column or the primary
column they reach
to the modulator which is at point
number one that modulator
slowly traps and releases small plugs
coming off of the primary column and
sends each of those plugs onto a
secondary column
it collects about two or three seconds
of effluent from the primary column
before sending that plug
onto the secondary column where it goes
through a second
independent mechanism of separation
what this means is that we are better
able to separate our compounds from one
another
because every uh part of our sample goes
through two different separations
and we still use a mass spectrometer to
detect the compounds at the end of that
process
so in gc or one-dimensional gc we have
a plot that basically shows us peaks for
each individual compound so we can see a
sample here
we've got five or six larger components
and a lot of smaller components in this
sample
with gcgc however we are able to
separate
in two dimensions because we have two
columns and if we look at our plots they
tend to look a little bit more like a
heat map where each of these individual
we could call them blobs that's actually
the term that's that's used
but each of these individual blobs would
represent an individual compound
and so we can see in this bottom plot
here there's still
a big chunk along the bottom that's not
resolved
but if we look to everything that's kind
of above that area
we can see many many components that
weren't
necessarily visible or separated in the
plot above so this is actually the same
sample analyzed by both techniques
so compared to gcms gcgcms provides us
with better
heat capacity and because we can pull
our compounds apart from one another
better
we have increased sensitivity and
detectability of our compounds
and our compounds show up in these kind
of patterns
along the plot that allow us to be able
to start identifying them more easily
this means that when we're doing
decomposition odor analysis we get more
information about the sample
we have improved visibility over
differences
from one sample to the next and
therefore we can actually just start to
focus
only on the compounds that are the most
important in our samples
because we can actually separate them
from things like background
and that's important because there are
so many variables that impact the
production of decomposition odor
we have intrinsic variables things
coming from the body or the carcass
itself
extrinsic variables like weather and
climate that are impacting the body
analytical variables like the type of
instrumentation that we're using the
type of maybe sorbent in our sorbent
tube so different analytical things
related to the collection and analysis
process
and taponomic variables like how long
has the body
actually been there um and
what scavengers are in the area etc
and we have started to study a lot of
these factors
um and so on the last slide you would
have seen asterisks
on different points where we've actually
started to study a lot of these
different
variables and from that a lot of the
studies have started to evolve and i can
say that the most effective studies have
some things in common
first off using animal models to develop
different methods is really helpful
because it allows us to have multiple
carcass replicates
this is helpful because we can start to
see how trends vary
from one body to another however of
course it's always
helpful and necessary for us to validate
those trends that we see
on human remains it's also helpful when
studies monitor
decomposition odor over more than just
a single point in time having a single
point in time
doesn't necessarily give us a full
picture
of what's actually happening
the it's also helpful when
representative control sites or
background sites are used
in replicate because this helps us to
develop better statistics
so that we can understand what's
happening in our samples and
differentiate
the background that may be coming from
things like soil or plants
or building components that maybe are in
the area
that aren't necessarily contributing to
decomposition odor but nevertheless
show up in the sample that's collected
it's also helpful to have analytical
controls for collection and analysis
so for example having blanks that help
to show
what volatiles are coming from the
stainless steel hood what volatiles are
coming from the sorbent tubes themselves
etc it's also helpful to use the
appropriate analytical tool for the
question at hand
so if a study is looking to perform
untargeted analysis
gcgc is going to be the better tool
because we have a better ability
to comprehensively separate all the
analytes in the samples
however if a study just wanted to look
at maybe five or ten volatiles and how
they are changing over time
a one-dimensional gc analysis may be
perfectly suitable
it's also helpful when studies report
significant compounds
in their samples based on statistical
variants i.e
how compounds change from one sample to
the next
not necessarily abundance if we look to
a lot of the earlier studies in the
field
researchers tended to focus largely on
the compounds that were the most
abundant and we now know
that some of the lower level compounds
are actually very important in that
profile as well
so over time we've been developing more
and more studies
in this area of research it started
around 2004 where the first study was
published
and now in 2021 there's approaching 50
published research papers specifically
on decomposition odor analysis
i have a couple asterisks here one at
2008 and one
in 2011 and that's because in 2008
there was the first occurrence of a case
where decomposition odor was collected
as evidence in the case in 2011 that
case went to trial
and that decomposition odor was
presented in court for the first time
this was at a time when there were fewer
than 10 published studies in the field
of decomposition odor
so i like to point out how far we've
actually come from that point
in exponentially increasing the amount
of research being conducted in this
field
and how much more helpful that
information could be you know to a case
that's similar to that at this point in
time
and if we look on the right hand side of
the slide we can see how the techniques
have been evolving
so the earlier on studies tended to
focus mostly on one-dimensional gc
whereas now we start to see a lot more
occurrence of comprehensive
two-dimensional gc
in these research papers
so what we know from a lot of these
studies is that
during the fresh stage which occurs
immediately after death
there are very few compounds present and
they tend to be lower in abundance
that's what we see here with low
concentration of compounds and lower
diversity in the fresh stage
once the body starts to decompose it
becomes bloated
and we get a lot higher concentration of
the compounds that are
that are being produced but still we
don't have too many compounds present
the active decay stage when there's a
large amount of insect activity and a
large amount of soft tissue loss
is when we have a peak in the
concentration of decomposition odor
as well as the diversity and the amount
of compounds we have
this is where the most compounds are
typically detected in all
studies and then in the advanced decay
stage
we start to see that those
concentrations start to diminish
because there is less soft tissue
present however we do see the
persistence of these at low levels
meaning that we maintain the diversity
of those compounds that's detected in
the profile
so again just to cover the the stages
and what's happening
during the fresh stage there are very
few vocs detected
all at low abundance in the bloat stage
that number of vocs will start to rise
but we have a lot of evolution of
concentration of those because
putrefaction is occurring
during active decay the vocs are at peak
production
because there's a lot of putrefaction
liquefaction and microbial processes
happening
and in a lot of studies we see thousands
of vocs detected at this stage
all at very high abundance the advanced
decay stage we start to see
the abundance of those vocs reduce
however the complexity of that profile
becomes maintained
and during the dry or remains or
skeleton stage
we reduce those number of compounds and
really the
the compounds that will be retained will
be the ones that are in the environment
that are the most persistent
so what we know about decomposition odor
right now is that we have at least
hundreds of compounds in about 10
different chemical classes
that this profile is dominated by sulfur
compounds
namely dimethyl sulfide dimethyl
disulfide
dimethyl trisulfide this odor starts
minimal
it will peak in abundance and complexity
and then it will reduce
and it's impacted by many factors
including temperature and humidity
and insect activity as probably being
the three main environmental factors
the the odor that we collect will be
slightly biased by our collection
methods so if we use different methods
of collecting this odor then we may get
slightly different profiles
however there is a subset of this
profile that is reproducible under
different conditions
in totally different environments at
totally different times of the year
we also know that live odor transitions
to postmodern or
post mortem odor after about 43 hours or
about two days postmortem
what we still don't know in this field
is
the mechanisms behind how a specific
compound is produced
so we can't necessarily track a starting
point to an
ending point in terms of which compounds
are being released
and we also don't know how to predict
the presence in the specific amount of a
compound at a very specific point in
time
meaning that we don't necessarily know
if we could use
certain compounds as markers of
post-mortem interval
we also still don't fully understand the
impact of microbial communities on this
odor and
we know that microbial communities have
a very big impact on how a body will
decompose
so that's still a big blind spot in this
field of research
and because we still have some of these
blind spots we don't necessarily know
how to interpret samples
if they are collected in casework so it
would be best for us to develop a better
understanding of this before again
presenting this type of research in
court
looking to a map these are some of the
areas in which voc studies on
decomposition odor have been conducted
if we look at climate classifications we
can see that the large majority of these
studies fall into the common class c
and d the area that i'm currently
located in
is actually common class a in honolulu
hawaii where we're actually designated
in the tropical rainforest category
so our most recent study focused on
looking at decomposition odor of pig
carcasses in this region
and seeing how that can compare to other
regions that have been studied around
the world
this is our field site in palolo valley
which is in honolulu hawaii
and we can see an aerial view on the
right-hand side
of you kind of looking out towards what
we call diamond head
if you've ever been to hawaii you
probably recognize it it's very close to
waikiki
and we also have a photo of some
researchers
outside at our field site taking some
measurements from a pig carcass
so this is a type of terrain that we are
typically looking at it's
very similar to a lot of the areas that
people go missing especially
missing hikers missing elderly people
etc
so it's very representative of you know
the scenario that i
i started this presentation with and in
studying this we monitor decomposition
odor over a two week period
which is typically about enough time in
hawaii for our
remains to go all the way to a skeleton
state or at least to advance decay
in this we were able to detect all major
compound classes that we know exist in
decomposition odor
except aromatics and alkanes the acids
sulfur compounds esters and nitrogen
compounds were the
most significant components of the
profile
the temporal trends or the trends over
time appear to exist for most major
classes
in very similar ways to areas such as
greece
canada and australia and obviously if we
want to compare
our study to other studies we can only
compare it to studies that have
similar study designs that monitor over
a similar
period of time etc and therefore
um you know this list is really only
repres this list of places that are
similar is really only representative of
studies
that have done similar types of research
or design their study in a similar way
if we look at these vocs by
decomposition stage we can kind of see
them separated
and we see how the vocs are lower in
abundance in the beginning and then they
kind of peak
and then eventually start to decrease
and
the sulfur compounds did start to
dominate that active decay stage which
is very similar to other studies
we see that the acids started to peak in
later decomposition again
these trends have high consistently with
similar data that are reported in
belgium and australia and so this is
very encouraging to see
that in a totally different climate we
can identify
new trends or sorry similar trends in in
new regions that are
you know consistent from one place to
another
and of course a lot of our research has
been impacted by the kovid 19 pandemic
um i wanted to give a bit of an idea of
how this kind of impacted our work
for those who don't know chaminade
university is a predominantly
undergraduate institution we're located
in honolulu on the island of oahu which
is what people probably considered the
you know the main
island in hawaii um and
uh we've been you know rather isolated
by
by an ocean border um throughout this
pandemic and so
that's been a benefit in some ways and
in other ways
kind of a barrier at least to our
research um
but in march 2020 we lost full access to
the university about
um two weeks into march uh was when that
first happened you know
very similar to i imagine what happened
around the entire world about that time
for us we were quite lucky that we
actually regained access for research
purposes
only to the university in may of 2020
and this was because an exemption was
uh was put in place in our locale
for research to continue and so the
university granted us
access however we had to go through
quite a bit of paperwork for every
researcher coming back on campus
we were only allowed to have limited
personnel in our space absolutely it
makes sense
because of what was going on we also had
to have
additional safety protocols in place
that obviously is necessary but also
impacts your productivity
and we had to train everybody on these
new protocols
and as well we were also training new
researchers in the laboratory on new
techniques and so
that makes it really challenging when
you're trying to train new people in the
laboratory but you have restrictions on
the the number of people you're allowed
to have in that space so it just changes
a little bit the way that
you know you have to work in august of
2020
um we actually started our fall semester
and at chaminade university
that was a fully online start to the
semester and so we did about six weeks
of online studying and then in october
2020 all of our classes resumed
face to face and we've been face to face
ever since with the option for students
to study online if they want to
and i point this out um because at
predominantly undergraduate institutions
or puis
a lot of our research space is actually
located
in classrooms and so that's a huge
consideration because through the summer
months
we were basically able to maintain
social distance and make sure that we
had limited people in those spaces
but as soon as classes resumed it became
a lot more challenging to book time in a
laboratory
to access the instrumentation to access
our data workstations and things like
that
so even though you know classes and
research at a lot of institutions are
taken completely
separately for us the start of classes
even online and face-to-face
actually did have quite an impact on our
ability to get in there and do work
from a field standpoint if we were to be
conducting field research
throughout this time of course impact to
field facilities could be challenging
so first off you have to make sure that
your personnel get access to your field
facilities
typically that involves preparing in a
laboratory environment
before going out to those field sites
you're talking about teams of
researchers needing to access those
facilities
so you know you have to think about
people driving together in a car
to that location by the institution
it may not be um there also may be an
impact of
impact of availability of research
specimens so for example
we get pig carcasses from a local pig
farmer
and so that can be challenging if
they're not willing to provide things
throughout you know these major
incidents in terms of funding if you're
working on an existing funding program
you really have to think about how are
you
going to make your funding program work
given a totally new timeline
granting agencies of course were very
understanding of setbacks to research
over the past year
however if you're working on you know a
multi-year
funding program um keeping
researchers employed and keeping
equipment running and maintenance going
and everything all of that is going to
be
impacted in the long term in how much
you can really achieve
throughout your funding program and also
this area of research is
an area where there's already very
minimal funding and there's been a huge
uptick in the number of
grant proposals that have been submitted
across i think
probably all areas of science right now
as people were
you know at home writing and compiling
you know previous data and things like
that throughout the pandemic and so
that funding availability could also be
an impact
you know moving forward at least in the
next year or two
in the laboratory a couple things that
we have to think about as well
obviously i've already kind of talked a
little bit about personal access to
laboratory
um but i also wanted to mention for us
one of the things that was
really challenging and completely
understandable from my perspective
was the level of commitment that my
researchers were able to put towards
their projects
my entire research group is
undergraduate researchers a lot of them
have part-time jobs
they're also studying full-time and they
have family commitments outside of the
university
and a lot of that really impacted the
ability for us to have really high
expectations
of how much could be performed in a
certain period of time
so we had to adjust a little bit the
expectations about
the commitment to you know performing
research hours because these are
part-time workers
we also had to think a little bit about
if we have team projects and multiple
people working on things how do we
organize to have them
in the laboratory at the right time how
do we make our workflow in terms of data
processing and all of that work properly
we had to think about how do we take
data that's on our
our computers here at the university
and how do we make that accessible for
researchers when they're working
remotely and things like that
the equipment also had to keep running
throughout this entire time so we needed
access to techno
or we we actually had limited access to
technicians we had two incidents where
we were supposed to have technicians
come out to do you know regular
maintenance
um and those things were were definitely
impeded as well
and being for us at least that we're an
island in the middle of the pacific
ocean
obviously we had challenges with
shipping of supplies
and we also have to think about how
we're using our funding for example
because um as we have to keep our
instruments running with helium
constantly which is very expensive
if we're not actually running samples
we're still actually funding the
the use of that instrumentation even
while it's sitting idle so
just some things that we had to kind of
think about and plan for at least as we
move into
an area of time where we hope things are
going to start to return a little bit
more back to normal
so in conclusion about this work i would
say that the field of decomposition odor
is still
relatively young it's developing but
it's getting there and we are
learning so much more through every
study about what this odor is
what the profiles look like and how that
can be applied in different scenarios
so we've learned a great deal about
these trends and how stable they are in
different areas
we still need some validation studies
some is probably an understatement i
would say a lot more validation studies
are needed to really put this into
practice
better modeling of this data that we've
even already collected to look at trends
maybe looking at using some more
advanced statistical models to
try to pinpoint how this odor is
impacted over time and maybe even use it
as a post-mortem interval
marker and also i talked a lot about the
different things that make a study
the most effective and i think
implementing those across a lot of
studies will be more helpful
for studies in the future and of course
cova 19 will have an impact on most
research groups to some extent either in
the laboratory or
the field or in both capacities and so
we have to also kind of understand
uh what we're up against moving forward
and hopefully you know
moving more into a time that's more
normal
and i just wanted to take a moment to
acknowledge all of the researchers in my
group
they are very hardworking we've all been
through a lot this past year
and it always amazes me every day that
they
continue to work so hard on their
research projects so i just want to
take a moment to thank everybody and
also to thank our
um to thank the organizers of this
conference
it's a pleasure to be able to be
involved um all of our funding agencies
and of course if you have any questions
you're more than welcome to reach out to
me
and i've just attached my email to the
bottom of this slide
thank you very much